so we're super lucky today to have a
double bill it's very rare that we get
both the venture capitalists and the
entrepreneur in the room at the same
time so we have Mike Morris who is a
legendary venture capitalist on his own
and one of his favorite entrepreneurs
Lisa sugar who runs popsugar and all the
brands associated with it I know most of
us woman who spent a lot of time on it
are excited to hear from her I wanted to
start today by asking a particular
question inspired by mikes book called
leading which was published in September
2015 in your book you say that leaders
know that success comes from making a
few big decisions correctly rather than
spending a lot of time being involved in
many small decisions so I wanted to ask
both of you to introduce yourself and
talk about some of the few really
important decisions you've made in your
life that have made you who you are okay
I get to go first no unless yeah all
right never being bashful long these
sorts of topics um I'm happy to go first
Lisa so I think whether whether you're
running an organization or whether
you're trying to wind your way through
life as you look back there are only a
few things that matter and I grew up in
and i work at Sequoia Capital I've
worked at Sequoia for a very long time
now and when I think of the things that
mattered in my life they're probably
professionally two decisions I've made
the help them bring me to this classroom
today the first was deciding to emigrate
from the United Kingdom and coming to
the US and the second was being
fortunate enough to be hired at Sequoia
in the early 80s
and everything else rippled out of those
to all the if I had done neither of
those things none of the rest of my life
would have worked out as it has how did
she make the first decision it was
probably very this about leaving Britain
it was probably very similar just
looking around the room at the decision
that lots of people in this room made
and certainly the decision made by the
gentleman who gave the money to finance
this Center Jensen wall which is that
there was far more opportunity in
America than there was in our respective
home countries very good very good how
about yourself hi I'm Lisa sugar I
started popsugar with my husband so that
is one of my big life moments was
actually finding the man I was going to
spend the rest of my life with who I
then never thought I would actually work
with but starting the company with him
and I would say also moving to San
Francisco because we are were born and
raised on the east coast and that's in
our blood and so being now here over 15
years I wonder what would life would
have been like if we did not come here
because I don't know punctured or would
have ever existed i think it was the
opportunities that were obviously out
here on the west coast and and seeing
the entrepreneurial spirit and the
opportunities out here to be able to
start a media company on the west coast
was because of where we were and that
move so knowing that you have a media
background as a media buyer and then you
just love of writing these articles that
it eventually became your passion your
company and knowing that you have a
journalism background as well having
written two books one on Steve Jobs went
on we have our cocoa 30 sorry sorry
hahaha three and more hopefully and was
it love at first sight yes that is a
very sexist way of uh no our our
decision about sequoias decision to
invest in pop sure it was like every
important investment decision that we
make we're at the beginning I think when
we first met Lisa and Brian it was just
all three people and so it was trying to
imagine what would be possible if good
things eventually happened and that's
always a huge leap into the unknown and
and a decision to get into business with
founders who you don't know all that
well at the beginning but who you hope
and expect great things of and we'd had
some experience in these sorts of media
related businesses on the internet and
so that certainly helped inform our
judgment but you know it was it was a
gradual process it when it's not instant
but there was clearly at the time that
leeson Bryant started the company an
opportunity to create a new
internet-based property that was
tailored to women sort of in the you
know 18 to 40 year old demographic and
so that's what and we thought there's a
big opportunity there and so that's what
led up to the decision and yourself you
must have been looking for multiple
different partners for your series a how
did you decide upon Sequoia and Mike
yeah I think for me maybe more as a
little more love at first sight I think
you know knowing his track record and
hearing wonderful things about people
who have worked with him but beat the
media thing was huge for me I mean this
was you know my dream was to build a
media company and to know that Mike's
background was in journalism and that
you know he had you know core attachment
to that and then just even coming from
New York and where media is everything
and the celebrities there are the
editors and chiefs and the you know
people who run the TV networks and
knowing that Mike had had known a lot of
these people it's it was something you
know I kind of looked up at that and
Susie right you were a first-time
entrepreneur when you were raised yes
you say yes mam na my husband was not
yes so he had had to use a serious miss
clean
he has had some early successes which
was great so in the beginning we really
we were just writing and building and I
started popsugar on my couch and I just
felt there was a void in the marketplace
for a really fun female friendly always
updated always needed something new I
was like addicted to writing really
really fast and I knew that our audience
was coming back often so I wanted to
give them a new content constantly so
the more I saw the numbers going up the
more I kept writing and it was Brian who
had come from great companies like Kmart
and j.crew and estee lauder and he saw
how fast popsugar was growing and he
said okay I'm couldn't my my other job
and let's go you know but you're
starting but you started it if memory
serves me right just by as a hobby
writing to you yeah my friend I wanted
to get in the habit of writing every day
because I loved media I loved getting
access to TV pilots for free and every
magazine for free but I really wanted to
start getting my own opinion out there
and started to write so really was for
fun for myself and to train myself and
in the beginning I wasn't even telling
my friends I was really doing it so when
I was finding this whole audience coming
to me and I knew it wasn't my core group
of people that I knew who you know I was
doing this ah it was very flattering to
see how quickly was growing and it just
fueled the fire for more so you saw the
market opportunity what did you see and
Lisa and Brian what character traits
that you see in them that gave you the
confidence to invest what we see in a
lot of others or other successful
founders which is a real sense about the
product or service in this case that
they wanted to build and a real
connection with in this case an audience
but I other times you'd say customers or
can well consumers and so that they had
a real sense of purpose and they're able
to explain as Lee suggested the sort of
product that they wanted to build why
people would and why they were confident
that there'd be lots of people that
would care about I'm going to ask a
slightly more pointed question you write
about finding the people who are
obsessed how do you
how do you determine if somebody is has
an obsession it's um it's it's it's a
good point and it's one that you know I
wrote about with wisps Alex and in this
book and I think it's a characteristic
of the most successful entrepreneurs
which is that they certainly at the
beginning of their company and often for
a very good long time are able to shut
out the rest of the world and just
devote themselves to what they're really
interested in doing and shut off all the
other distractions because there's
really only one thing that they care
about and that care is deep and it's
genuine and it's the sort of thing that
they go to bed you know go to sleep
thinking about and they wake up in the
morning thinking that do you agree I do
our first tagline for pop sure was
insanely addictive and after some
marketing team folks came in and said no
one wants to be insane or addicted but
we just felt it really work I think it
was you know what fueled just to be able
to write about all the other verticals
you know to keep going and figure out
what people wanted to hear from us about
and what we weren't covering and you
know what what we had in our site and
vision from the beginning and you know
add new things that we added in along
the way as well so it's been 10 years
yes congratulations thank you hello
rooting her 10-year anniversary you've
played many roles from being a founder
with two or three of you in a room
series a with a lot of people now and
many many more brands and now you're the
president popsugar how have your roles
changed over the years and how have you
maintain that flexibility and how has
Mike guided you through those
transitions yeah I think what I love
about it so much as it has changed I
think actually getting away from the
writing was the hardest for me
personally because I really enjoyed
writing so much in the beginning but
once all the sites were launched and we
were getting bigger and we were
launching a sales team and you know
marketing and getting out there doing
things like this this is you know making
sure that I get out and I'm not behind
the scenes I'll
the time which I really like to do I
like the nitty-gritty of deciding what
the next show is that we're going to
launch and who the talent is but that
those are the new things you know video
is something we didn't launch with and
adding video to the business and
learning all about just how the studio's
work and how to create content for
various places that people are going to
consume it it changes I mean every year
it's changing for us so it's the
combination of wearing the different
hats and working a lot with the
different departments beyond just the
Edit team which is really still where I
spend a lot of my time it's still near
and dear and the strategy that I want to
spend a lot of time with growing that
team and keeping the sites growing the
way they haven't growing have been some
of the tough spots along the way yeah
ten years um I would say we were
definitely slower to adapt to mobile I'd
like to always say that probably every
board meeting Mike would pick up his
phone and you're like what's next on
this and you know we're like a well
they're just already reading it on the
on the phone but really being you know a
mobile-first mobile-centric across the
board so whether the site is easy to
read whether we have a subscription box
that's a monthly subscription box
whether you can purchase that really
easily all the integration into our
shopstyle site and making it easy to
shop from the phone as well as the
editors thinking about grabbing you with
that headline you know while you're
running down you know on your courting
commute or going to get lunch or in the
elevator getting all your news you know
really really adapting to thinking about
mobile first I think is probably the
biggest we were a little slower to that
but we're now seventy percent of our
audience comes from mobile so we're
figuring that out no early on building
we had a distribution partner early on
in the company a sales and distribution
partner and then making the decision to
build our own sales force that was a
tough and wrenching decision yeah why
was it a tough adventure decision well
we were really excited about
concentrating on the content and
building the audience but then you want
muck to have revenue right and we really
wanted to be a profitable company and so
we wanted to bring sales in house and
that's that's an expensive undertaking
to build a sales team but one that has
been wonderful for us and we are
profitable
so you have been for five years so yeah
and how has Mike what has your
relationship been like because we we
oftentimes don't talk about what you
celebrate when a round is raised and we
celebrate that what what has the
relationship then like in the past 10
years along the way it's gramatik is the
first time we met you write me a board
meeting yesterday um no it's been great
we have you know lots of board meetings
but not too many you know and mike is
always there in between any official
meeting for advice that that we need
helping you know helping recruit talent
you know helping connect us to people
that we want to work with all wonderful
ways doesn't make no mistake about it
this is bryan and lisas company and and
they they deserve a hundred and ten
percent of the credit cuz he's very
supportive yeah that's important yeah so
what's next ten years what do the next
ten years look like well i turned in a
book today so that is a that was a big
project that i was very excited to be
working on and again seeing how you know
mike has been successful with his books
and and talking to an audience of 18 34
year old women and the needs that they
come to us for you know we wanted to get
a book out there to talk to them about a
lot of the stuff that they the advice
that they want so when's that coming in
hopefully by September title we're still
working on it send ideas do ya yes I'm
aiming on work hard play nice just kind
of our mantra and you know basically how
to power your happy power you're happy
as another theme we talked a lot about
our content powers a lot of people's
happy so kind of that how to how to find
your route to living your best life and
yeah so the book is a big thing video is
still really big for us so looking at
other other places to have video
distributed creating scripted going on
netflix something down that route we
have another business called shopstyle
which is an amazing search tool if you
guys are ever looking to buy anything
specific you go to it you say you know
black and white pumps and I get every
shoe from Saks Nordstrom's forever 21
Neiman
j.crew and then you know you can get
sale alert it's it's very very easy use
its immense Amanda men and women yes and
children and furniture pretty much
anything so and we have you know
excellent retail partners we send a lot
of traffic to the Neiman's to targets of
the world so building out that business
and making it even easier for you
because we all know we want you know the
insta carts and the amazon prime's and
that instant gratification so making it
even easier and also our editors are
writing stories all day long about you
know what you need you know whether it's
the latest gene or you know some new hot
trend that's happening so that just to
integrate it all in and make it seamless
is our goal tell me a company that you
really admire oh I love Disney Disney is
one of those companies i just think
going back to our mantra even of
powering your happy it's there's a lot
of overlap there and i think what they
do whether it's the experience of
actually being in the park or that i'm
creating content to merchandise they
figured out lots of ways to make money
and keep their key stay true to their
vision and their mantra and their values
and i think that that's a company that i
look at that does a great job i loved
what you had to say about work hard and
play nice how does that get implemented
day-to-day like your inner you're the
founder president here the head of this
company you and Brian have run it and
how do you how do you make sure that
that is lived out and I mean we're in it
we're in it with everyone you know we
sit with everyone Brian and Brian's
favorite thing you know I would like to
think it's a nice family vacation but
it's really like a hackathon I mean if
you sent him away to just go in code
he's the happiest man so really just
being in it with everyone and you know
as we grow were you know 450 people now
like really still trying really hard to
have a company culture that feels like a
family when mic'd walked through the
door 10 years ago our daughter Katie was
born like the first day she came two
weeks early which was really the first
day of training at her house with our
founders and I went into labor and she
came to the office of this for the first
three years and so that that whole
family culture that we have and you know
the fact that Brian and are there
together every day you know we really
try to have that feeling go through but
at the same time
you know we are obsessed with this job
in this company that we're building so
we are always on working really hard and
we expect the same from our team and
finding people who are really passionate
to join the team and be a part of it and
help us grow I also read that popsugar
is sixty percent or more women
seventy-five percent oh I'm sorry we're
a lot of ladies yes we're 75% women our
exec staff is for fifty fifty engineers
or thirty percent women women have a
longer time with us or the tenure was
longer with us so yeah a lot of girls
for Brian we've three daughters a female
dog and he gets really mad women so so
one of the reasons we changed our our
colors from pink to blue but why are
your hopes and dreams for popsugar in
the next ten years I thought it
continues as Lisa said doing what it's
doing and as it's done very steadily and
predictably for a good long time carving
out a larger position in the evolving
landscape of media focused at the Omni
demographic that companies long been
dialed into you've acquired a lot of
companies in the last ten years how do
you look for great companies to acquire
to become part of your family that's a
good question Brian's is a definitely
more that's like a more fun project for
him i would say then myself but it's
it's finding same things that might get
mentioned earlier finding people who are
really obsessed about something filling
a need that we might have so whether
it's great technology on the shop style
end and finding engineers who are doing
great things from the shopping search
capabilities to we bought a company
called circle of bombs years ago because
you know our audience is really young
and we knew that the mom audience would
have been is really great for sales and
so bringing them in to our fold was it
was a great audience builder for us for
moms
yeah well before I open up for questions
from the audience I have one more
question for you you have 500 students
sitting in the audience think back to
when you were in college many many years
ago like me I couldn't get credit just
sitting through Leslie afternoon without
a notepad you know checking out my
facebook feed to shake if you were
sitting in the audience mm-hmm what
would you tell your younger self if you
could go back to that time and give
yourself yeah piece of advice Greenwoods
what's up three words three words all
right follow your instincts which is
very very easy to say be incredibly
difficult to do a little more context
everybody when they're wondering about
what they should do after college or
after University of you have the weight
of expectations on your shoulders you
have college bills that you might have
to pay you have parents who have
expectations for you in a particular
direction and whether you like it or not
subconsciously you carry all that stuff
with you and if you want to go in a
different direction from what you've
been spent your the previous 20 25 years
of your life almost being programmed to
go and do that's a very difficult thing
to do how about you Lisa I think for me
it was more it's more that it's just
okay if you don't have it figured out
yet I mean you know when I left College
the internet barely started so the job
that I would create for myself there's
no way I would have known that that's
why I was going to do and I didn't know
a hundred percent what I wanted to do
yet so i think i think really it's also
it's trying new things and just getting
yourself out there and experimenting and
figuring out what it is you're
gravitating towards and and liking and
then follow that direction thank you
well i'm going to open it up to the
floor for questions do we have a mic so
how it works okay I speak loud
and clearly let's start with the front
row oh yeah so I believe popsugar wants
people to be Lily engaged with the
website you want them to come back you
want that more you want more people
coming back to you what they say right
so internally how do you figure out the
user behavior like how can you keep them
more engaged yeah how do you internally
together what's that mechanism how to
figure that out that twenty percent of
audience like this kind of stuff already
put some leg dish how do you figure that
I i think you know we definitely do a
lot of deep dives content we're looking
at what people are excited about when
they come but then even just engineering
the page appropriately to have related
stories and bubble up content around
that they would be interested in having
never-ending galleries so they can go
right into one story to the next we also
have more of what we're calling a push
strategy this year as opposed to a pull
so a lot of us are you know getting a
lot of our our audience to come to us
through search and through social so
we're pulling them in but now we want to
push out to you so you know emails been
around forever and existed but even just
like push notification so getting more
people to download our app so that we
can you know give you news alerts
throughout the day on your watch and
your phone is something that we are
constantly testing now actually I think
more particular question be do you guys
you guys do big data analysis on the
comments that user make on your website
yes an article so yes so um we didn't
wait uh-oh what's don't we do a big data
analysis on the on the comment on the
comments yeah so I would say each editor
is looking at all aspects of their story
and they will go in and look
specifically at what people are reacting
to and will follow trends and we have
lots of ways that we can look at that on
the shop style side we can definitely
play more with the big data and what
people are searching on and where
they're clicking and go down that okay
so your night we actually do the big get
analytics so if I wrote an article you
may leave you uncheck it like what
people are commenting write something
about sorry yes if it's a story thank
you okay
I question for Mike Sequoia aside what's
what do you see the role of like metric
app is tweeting and posting on social
media and that connection to that
activity to the firm's success question
is the connection between a venture firm
being active on social media and its
success it'll be quite a long time
before anybody is going to be able to
answer that question because social
media is a marketing platform is is
fairly recent in the grand scheme of
things and obviously Sequoia was around
a long time before the web came along
and social media and mobile and
everything else I think it's easy to get
distracted by the sound of the trumpet
and the what matters eventually is the
quality of the investment decisions that
are made and the acuity with with which
those are made and it's somewhat similar
to to you know the analogy that people
used to make when newspapers were read
more frequently than they are today
which is not to get sucked up into
believing believing your own headlines
and so I think especially in this sort
of today's era humility also goes a long
way particularly in a business's
humbling as the investment business or
the venture business which if you don't
make the decisions correctly can hand
you out a right royal spanking no matter
how high your public profile and let's
do the one in the back red shirt with
stripes Oh lovely hi um I'm is Matt
DeLorean oh just mama seen a soft
we're Stanford um but I was intrigued
that you that you had mentioned that you
that this needs a company that you
admire our firms at about 30 year old
Lincoln ship with Disney um actually and
Sweeney who is this who is the and if
you know an or not she's actually my
daughter's godmother if you like that
introduction look I love to meet with
you I'm sure love to me thank you thank
you let's do one more from the back
young man is a white shirt you mentioned
that popsugar was late to mobile but it
sounds Michael like you are pushing them
to go there are there any innovations or
trends you're seeing that you'll be
pushing media companies to get on Jeff a
relative you can introduce me to well
one thing we talked about yesterday when
we all met popsugar is what we're doing
to address this huge phenomenon of you
know twitch game streamers and there's a
big you know that is not a masculine
preserve and so that's an audience and
an activity that is enormous and growing
and I think Lisa and the other editors
agree that we could be doing doing more
on that so I think staying alert just as
as the company's done over the last
decade and and not you know not getting
blindsided by a new trend like this that
just seemingly comes out of nowhere in
the last 18 months and getting on it
very quickly and just remaining I in the
most important thing to do is to remain
vigilant about these new sorts of
opportunities because it's easy to fall
asleep at the at the wheel as they
along cool please professor yes I'm
tising and Michael thank you for
everything that you've done for the
valley since I'm came here this single
more than that I met Michael the first
time when he agreed to you interviewed
for a case like Abu um accepting his
first round of capital than him dazzling
Massey oceansun we said well how do you
know what you think yahoo is worth and
Michael said 500 billion dollars and not
serious son was flabbergasted I guess
these days people would say 500 million
is at all but you have been guiding
entrepreneurs for a long time I just
want to thank you what if thanks Tom
it's not me at Sequoia unlucky enough to
be part of Sequoia but now could I jump
jalisa did you go to CES I did not Brian
my husband did I mean last year was
riding the uber because there was
something who looks like we might have
been you vitamin goodness / be / be
sorry little electric scooter oh it's
definitely not me the general question
is um when you're trying to think about
what's happening you see yes interesting
yeah you figure out what's most
interesting because the article to be
roses question okay so I have editors um
how do we think about ces when we go it
is interesting to us consumer electronic
show because not everybody knows yes so
that consumer we have covered it from an
editorial point of view how do we look
at the Consumer Electronics Show is that
something that's important to popsugar
and we look at it two ways we send an
editorial team who is covering the
trends and the products that are there
and how they would relate to women 18 to
40 and how will be excited about new
things that are be introduced into our
lives so you know female journalists
there in a predominantly male space and
then we also go from a corporate
perspective where I mean it's now just a
meeting ground where all CEOs and you
know teams are meeting and talking about
trends and doing panels and so on so you
know Brian and I sort of divide and
conquer a lot of times there are key
things that we do go to together and
last year i did go with him but this
year
I let him so do you go to see you this
year so he handle that see the the lady
with the red and black shirt is
primarily for Lisa what are some of the
ways you navigated the challenge of
running a profitable media company in
the Internet age when the mentality is
that high quality content should really
yes um we are definitely we like to
still run like a start-up which I know
as hard as we are as large as we are we
have a wonderful CFO who actually
attended the school and he likes to he's
cautious and he wants us to be able to
take risks and invest in stuff but there
are times when we definitely have
started a project and realized this
isn't for us we shouldn't go down this
route anymore and let's just concentrate
on the core which is you know the
content and our great shopping tool and
make it as you know wonderful as we can
for our audience try not to ruin the
experience by taking too many ads you
don't want to like ruin the experience
for the reader on the side yes you've
not SBC is an end as an entrepreneur um
in general what has been the power well
it's two against one so there's never I
didn't notice how much are no I think
it's been very amicable okay let's go to
the back the man in the light blue shirt
hi my name is Nicholas yeah so I just a
question here do you believe that there
will be another Steve job they will
happen in next five to ten years and why
know any more than I believe there'll be
another larry page or Mark Zuckerberg or
Bill Gates there each very distinctive
personalities now if the question is is
there somebody that whose name we don't
know today who 20 years from now will be
very well known because of a company
that he or she started absolutely yes
yes right I'm serious if you tell us
about a big decision that you think you
got around this is wrong well I can
think of investment decisions lovely
daughter wrong too many too as far as
like I mean we started the sites we had
an original vision of 12 sites that we
wanted to launch and we realized shortly
that there were certain verticals that
weren't an everyday read so i would say
that there were certain things that we
restructured to make the content package
the right way that's not really actually
i'm curious like if you would talk about
an investment decision that i'm sideways
like was that nor oh thank you for
bringing that up emily the two syllable
company that's gonna home you know
Webvan we invested in this company web
man and sometimes you know people are
people say well you know what's going to
happen in the end is i always tell
people that i'm gonna get cremated and
they say why are you gonna get cremated
cuz i said i don't want to have a
tombstone
but reads here lies the idiot who
invested in web fan yeah so that was
fortunately however we we got one thing
right in the web an investment 17-18
years ago which is the incredible
insatiable consumer demand for delivery
at home for groceries and fortunately
have recovered from that and there now
many years later very very happy
investors in a company called instacart
which serves this area down here and if
you haven't tried it you should because
it's it's everything that Webvan wanted
to be anymore 17 years ago and as Lisa
who is a very happy customer said softly
just then and far more because of the
acuity the founder but also the advances
in technology but wet ban is the
investment that will always hold so when
you say that not all this bad decisions
are bad there's there's a silver lining
to some of the bad decisions that were
made there's learnings their learnings
yeah yeah there is nothing worse than
investors here than this has been a
learning experience because because what
that really means is this has been a
really costly and expensive experience
all right in the orange shirt thank you
I'm laura's thank you for being here
Lisa what do you think about the new
generation generation see and Mike what
what what are your challenges what do
you think or what would you like to do
better oh I love the next generations I
love hiring youth and studying them i
think that uh huh users i mean as yeah i
think it's fascinating i think the idea
that you know they consume a lot more
they share a lot more they're just you
know very fast instant gratification
relatability personalization all that
stuff
that is a lot of the core of what
popsugar started with when we started
and wanted to be you know a in the no
source that came across as a girlfriend
and not in the know and or not you know
it all so in the know but not a
know-it-all and I think that that's how
they want to be talked to and they want
you know i love how diverse it is and
how open people art all shapes sizes
colors everything it's it's great and i
think that you know it's only going to
get better so we're totally embracing it
and love it
Oh red Stanford calidius okay thanks for
the to Michael I'm wondering what would
you say are the best obvious reasons why
Sequoia is still the at the top of the
venture capital world and by obvious
then correct me if I'm wrong but maybe
you would say team and network career
some other reasons did you see a need to
clear up there well that's a very nice
question thank you a question was why do
I think Sequoia is the preeminent
venture firm I don't I think I think I
always feel we're always one step away
from going out of business and that we
can never take anything for granted and
we're only as good as our next
investment and we can never be good
enough wow you have a lot of fans of
second row yeah thank you um question so
a question came up earlier round what is
the next 10 years of life and how do you
what what happens when a company of a
wildly successful profitable company
wants to remain private and independent
but for a venture firm that has a
10-year life and has to return capital
to its limited partners how do you think
about you know that next 10 years if
you've been involved already 10 years
mm-hmm the question was does a company
like popsugar where we've been in
investor for a long time does the design
of the 10 or 12 your venture partnership
mean that we have to sell our shares
fortunately the investors in Sequoia
entities that we call limited partners
they're very relaxed about it and so if
we feel that there are companies which
where we want to continue holding the
shares inside the partnership
they're very comfortable permitting
allowing us to do that and we've done
that on a on a number of occasions
because I think all of us the limited
partners in Sequoia realize the pressing
for quote liquidity at inopportune times
or when the future is remains looking
very bright and there's no reason for
the company to go public it's not in
anybody's interest so it's not a big
issue for us maroon shirt that's you um
speaking of liquidity events how'd you
see venture funding evolving with higher
interest rates and market crashes like
this week in the next two years a
question was what happens to venture
funding when interest rates go up if um
it's no accident that in the world of
alternatives doesn't matter where you
look it can be the royal and gas
industry it can be the venture industry
it can be the real estate industry the
flood of capital into the private
portion of those businesses since
interest rates have come way down has
risen because everybody there every is
looking for returns on their investments
so as interest rates move up the capital
will retreat and if you're asking me
when is that going to happen I have no
idea but obviously as interest rates go
up and people feel that they can get
reasonable returns with far less risk or
perceived risk then the money will
retreat out of the private markets okay
I'm gonna have three more questions so
second row yes
so you've always advised a college
freshman and pretty much everybody to
four legs instincts but do you think
that's more of like an intuitive thing
or is it something that can actually be
hooked up with experience of taking
risks or question was the the advice I
offered I don't know whether it's good
or bad that people should follow their
instincts whether I could say a little
bit more about that I think it helps if
you try and enter an environment where
you think you can learn a lot and
whether that's inside an organization
doesn't happen have to be a company it
can be a be some other organization or
around people that you particularly
admire that you can learn a lot from and
I think that just helps expand ones
horizons and also gives the the
individual a sense of what excellence is
really like if you pick the right
setting all the right set of individuals
and done right it's a transformative set
of experiences and massively expands
your horizons and the sense that you
have of all the wonderful array of
opportunities that lie in front of you
curious actually Lisa do you agree I do
I think that that surround yourself with
great people and try new things
absolutely right row in the purple
thanks sir michael what Silicon Valley's
I can
learn for Alex owners or so question was
about this book that I wrote recently
with the manager of Manchester United
sir alex ferguson and what the lessons
are that people in the valley could take
from the figure who is the most
successful coach of a professional
sports team in history and an and vice
versa and as I got to know him and as we
were writing the book together it struck
me the sort of attributes of leadership
that he has and demonstrated for so long
a very very similar to the attributes
that you see among the very best company
founders in Silicon Valley and it was
also pretty apparent to me and this may
sound too bland for every video I wish
there was a bigger surprise that the
characteristics of leadership is
embodied in an individual whether you're
running a soccer club in the north of
England in the rain or a technology
company in cupertino in the sunshine a
very very similar there are some
differences obviously I think hiring
people in in his pursuit errs is all
retaining people in his pursuit is a lot
easier than it is in Silicon Valley his
business the business of soccer is a
much slower business moving business
than the world of technology so there
are some differences but I sent the book
to there's a very very famous he's one
of my heroes called he was an early
the leader one of the leaders of the
first generation of venture capitalists
who invested in apple and and Intel and
he was the first investors in in in in
the early investors in both of those
companies a gentleman called Arthur Rock
and he's in his 80s and how do you wrote
me a very sweet note last week and he
said I just finished the book and I
would hire sir alex ferguson to run any
company in which I was in investing very
cool alright last question in the white
perhaps a bit too specific a question
but based on your experience how
realistic do you think for a start-up to
be able to do BGC mb to be at the same
time and there's an early spirit rhythm
how realistic is it for a company to do
b2c and b2b at the same time we I'm sure
there are examples of companies that
have pulled it off I just think right at
the beginning you have to concentrate on
doing one thing super well and once
you've done that the second thing
becomes becomes easier particularly if
you're dealing with it's one thing to
sell precisely the same product to both
audiences and if you can do that bless
your heart so it's a it's a good thing
to do but I think it's very diff you've
got to tailor the product differently I
think that's a very dangerous thing for
a company to do right at the start you
know it's no coincidence obviously the
Apple under under steve jobs was not
prepared to compromise a change and
alter its products to please
corporations they would build products
and if corporations wanted to buy them
so be it but they weren't going to come
up with with special products and it was
it was an approach that obviously served
them serve them very well and then as
you know there plenty of examples of
other companies
have overtime succeeded in with two
different sorts of distribution channels
plenty of examples of that but at the
beginning I think simplicity is a virtue
all right we're totally at a time and
clear there are more questions so feel
free to come on up afterwards if you
want to speak to the two of them
separately and we'll see you next week
you